[Musique]
la vie si tous kankan est astucieux
c'est aussi le plus sérieux sami est à
jouer il s'est dit vouloir devenir un
ami
tu sais bonjour là bonjour tout cas
encore j'ai eu de la chance je croyais
être en retard non c'est bien tu as
juste à l'heure c'est parfait pas de
problème je trouvais pas mais vers c'est
pas possible
et comment ça se fait que steve et j'ai
trouvé les avais tu me jeter peas
étaient encore en terre je vois que tu
m'a préparé des dessins oui oui oui
c'est toujours le jeu wii et des
sandales chics hervé legrand tissu
d'intelligence et de logique
voyez d'astuces et de et d'attention
parce que ça te fait plaisir de les
présenter avant suite les dessins oui
avez lu je le fais oui oui je voudrais
de voir l ouvrage ah bah alors nous
allons présenter ce premier dessin qui
m'a pas je reprends oui c'est ça qui se
passe dans bas dans la rue comme vous
pouvez le constater c'est une ville une
scène de la rue je vous rappelle qu'il
faudra mettre les dessins dans l'ordre
tout à l'heure le second des saints row
c'est toujours une race est toujours la
même celle c'est le même c'est la même
scène
enfin c'est pas tout à fait le même
quand même hein ce n'est pas tout à fait
le même mot je vois déjà une différence
nous allons voir le troisième des saints
ah oui là c'est c'est même assez
différent il ya un harry un ordre
logique et coutumes me semble que moi
j'ai trouvé parce que sam ça me paraît
tout de même ça assez évident c'est le
problème de la version hebbadj est donné
ma version
moi je crois que c'est le problème des
feuilles alors nous avons commencé par
regarder la scène dans laquelle il y a
peu de feuilles tomber de l'arbre sur la
tête ce dessin là et je mettrai ce
dessin en numéro 1
les feuilles commencent à tomber il
serait donc tout à fait logique
d'enchaîner avec le dessin sur lequel il
y a déjà un peu plus de feuilles c'est à
dire celui là ça me paraît intelligent
ça me paraît logique et ensuite on
terminerait par le dessin sur lequel au
pied de l'arbre s'entassent cette fois
ci de très nombreuses feuilles une année
moi j'ai perdu mes plumes ça faisait
face à haye abri oui oui c'est à ça tu
as fait peur peut-être cette affaire là
non pas tant pis s'il a un temps et
remis quand même - non mais c'est
l'essentiel voilà comment il fallait je
crois classés
et dessins ce pas trop difficile cette
fois ci mais en bien comme ça ah oui oui
et amusant alors on va passer si tu veux
un point commun bon je sors alors pour
sam toujours voilà nos jardins je sors
je sors je savais va vous en faites pas
remis j'arrive
oui tiens gros malin la dignité vous
êtes en forme tous les deux oui vous
savez ce que vous avez à dire et à faire
oui oui alors on appelle fabrice en
appel qui avait la plus à l'est je me
sens dans une forme internationale et je
crois que je vais gagner normes
internationales ça ne veut rien dire si
ça veut dire une forme internationale
comme pour un sportif va être gentil le
jeu et du point commun et ben je vais le
rappeler ce jeu du point commun si tu le
veux bien vous allez chacun représenté
quelque chose à nous dire ce que vous
êtes et nous devons tous ensemble aussi
bien vous que moi découvrir quel est le
point que vous avez en commun voilà en
avant bon ben je commence allez tu vas
pas déçu bon c'est pas facile hein
aujourd'hui haïti
je suis dans la terre faut creuser pour
me trouver
il ya déjà depuis quelques années
d'ailleurs il faut bien le dire les
hommes se donnent beaucoup de mal pour
me découvrir
il n'épargne ni leur peine ni leur
argent d'ailleurs ils ont raison car
quand il me trouve je peux leur livrer
des trésors
enfin ce que ce que vous appelez des
trésors parce que moi je ne partage pas
vos idées là-dessus mais les hommes
grâce à ce que les trouve chez moi ils
s'éclairent il se chauffe
ils font marcher toutes sortes de
machines ils font tourner leurs usines
tout ça serait très bien s'il n'y avait
pas la pollution aux voitures mais alors
ça c'est le dernier de leurs soucis
voilà oui j'ai fini j'ai trouvé bon
après c'est pas facile quoique moi je
suis plus facile à trouver
on me voit partout sur tous les
vêtements d'homme ou de femme sur les
vestons les blousons les pantalons les
par dessus les gilets les imperméables
sur les vêtements de travail tu sais les
tabliers les blues et sur les uniformes
militaires alors là il y en a il y en a
chez moi aussi on peut trouver des
trésors à fabrice je vois passer
tellement de choses je suis très bien
placé pour savoir que les gens
non pas à la pause conçu un bar ou au
mois moi je suis très très rare oui ce
que je suis on ne rencontre pas souvent
il ya quelques animaux qui en ont mais
ce ne sont pas des animaux de nos
régions
je vais même te dire la vérité j'en ai
vu qu'une seule fois ces animaux là oui
c'était dans un jardin zoologique oui il
paraît que ce sont les animaux qui
vivent seulement en australie -
l'australie mais je connais pas mais je
me rappelle très bien le jour où j'en ai
vu au zoo c'était très amusant à
regarder
ils ont une façon de marcher tellement
spéciale à la vérité il marche pas il
saute
tu vois ce que je veux dire où je vois
dans ton oeil que tu as compris
oui mais ça pas été sans mal a à ce
qu'il faut bien dire cette fois ci
c'était difficile car en réalité vous
n'avez pas dû au départ ce que vous
étiez très exactement
alors on pouvait se tromper ma quand
j'ai entendu tout con quand baugé tout
de suite bien entendus pensez au pétrole
en partant du pétrole je voyais pas le
rapport avec les vêtements dont parlait
bell bell est encore mois avec l'animal
et que tu viens d'évoquer mais c'est en
trouvant le nom de cet animal que
brusquement l'éclair s'est fait dans ma
tête ça a sauté aux yeux
sacrément tu es un kangourou oui bon
alors un kangourou qu'est ce que tu as à
une eau bio oui oh il y a des poches de
pétrole est bien entendu y est il y
avait une bosse sur les vêtements y
aller vous parle est rare et voilà
cessons donc les poches qui sont les
points communs et voilà très bien si
t'es pas facile bien mais passait très
bien fini ah ben ça alors on peut
continuer notre parcours lui trouve un
sujet belle belle vallée va aller se
cacher oui mais
je ne sais pas ce que je vais te
présenter aujourd'hui une seconde à
s'allier seuil et je sais ce que je veux
est-ce que tu as ton petit matériel
on garde la tête haute a pas oublié
pourrait manquer bien l'esprit on est
bon ben alors on va faire notre petit
jeu comme d'habitude alors j'espère que
tu essaieras de ne pas faire trop de
fautes d'orthographe
je crois que je vaux je crois que j'ai
bien travaillé cette semaine alors cette
fois ci c'est un mot en six lettres doit
support c'est pas terrible ainsi l'acte
mais alors ça n'avance pas alors la
lumière
oui la première lettre c'est un m m
alors un petit train de 3,4 et la
dernière lettre un e
ah voilà
bon alors maintenant tu devines alors
est ce que c'est un animal non un animal
est ce que c'est un arbre non c'est pana
est ce que c'est une fleur la non non
c'est pas une fleur tu brûles est ce que
c'est une plante
oui oui c'est une plante d'une plante
est ce que c'est une plante verte oui il
plante verte qui veut que tu veux que je
t'aide ou un vase y tiens je te donnerai
pas là la troisième ou la quatrième
parce que tu trouverais tout de suite
hein c'est trop facile
mme ashton la deuxième lettre 1 la
deuxième à l'hérésie
c'est un aaa à aa
voilà à l'at il va trouver une plante
verte m'a alors une plante s est ce que
c'est une plante que l'on trouve souvent
dans l'eau région au oui partout souvent
dans les champs elle a un goût très
particulier c'est bon c'est pas mauvais
ça sent bon ça sent bon fils et bon au
goût
ah bon ça se mange ni à ça se mange
oui ça se mange tout ça ce ça se soit
là-bas en infusion en infusion jetait
dans la pluie attendue
un baby mécènes moi je pense bien une à
une infusion moi je pense tout de suite
à l'infusion de monte à oui bah c'est ça
la menthe
tu as trouvé il est fort challenge
nantais jeu non je n'en peux plus me
tuera il ne tuera
qu'est ce que je t'ai fait menthe oui
même hors de la menthe
mais m am en ph e alors que tout le
monde sait que nous pauvres pouces
moussu commente ça c'est gris m e nth
eux
voilà comme on écrit man tu avais bien
mis 1 h tu vois j'avais fais attention
puis j'apprends à me un an
bon j'ai mis un an au news and once
moussu tu sais lalalalala sont pas
raisonnables moi je vais pas de quoi
faire j'ai pas écoute écoute écoute la
burqa qui est si fort est ce que tu sais
clamant c'est une plante qui pousse très
facilement
on s'en occupe même pas le seul problème
c'est que si on ne s'en occupe pas il ya
des tas d'herbe qui pousse tout autour
et on finit par plus d'avoir lamentin
alors dans ce cas là qu'est ce qu'on
fait peux-tu te le dise je te le donne
en mille il faut lâcher un troupeau
d'oies dans l'endroit où il ya de la
menthe des oies oui des lois parce que
les oies et mangent n'importe quoi sauf
la menthe est déteste la menthe ou t'es
sympa quand j'aurai un jardin et bien
j'aurai des oies je vais suivre ton
conseil si j'ai un jardin jour et que je
vais y faire pousser de la menthe
j'achèterai d oise oise
voilà sinon faits précis mais je regarde
là il faudrait refaire faire le toit là
haut avec williams et l'inde
il ya plein de jour loi fabrice si on
allait voir bell bell va voir
[Musique]
la mafia fabrice j'étais propose de
jouer à notre jeu des bonnes notes mais
sur un rythme tout à fait différent ils
baisseront pas alors moi je crois qu'on
pourrait peut-être avant de reprendre ce
jeu musical jeux théâtre et rapide coup
d'oeil sur les notes pour les avoir bien
en mémoire et les à prendre au cas où on
ne les connaîtraient pas très bien le
dos ça me sens clé de sol bien sûr do ré
seydoux la mi fa sol la si une aide au
dollar alors maintenant je suis apte ou
non à l'or donc nous prenons un rythme
différent parce que nous allons faire du
sens à l'heure c'est pourquoi je
voudrais qu'on parle d'automobiles ça
t'intéresse j'adore les automobiles j'en
ai eu
mais si tu ne retire un peu spécial
c'est bien fait mais pas très récente
elle date de dunes en fin je ne sais
plus très bien mais elle date de quelque
chose en tout cas elle appartenait à mes
parents c'est une somptueuse thorpe et
je l'adorent fait une une somptueuse
thorpe et oui une toque
oui vous avez tous compris voilà une
torpédo fêtes d'obernai la sucer je ne
m'en sers pas tous les jours deux ou
trois fois par an les partants éléments
à faire une longue promenade quand je
conduis moi même on le sait quoi que je
suis très douée mais hélas je suis
obligé de constater que les femmes au
volant sont victimes de l'injustice et
de la mauvaise foi de tous les
conducteurs et de tous les policiers dia
allons bon ni refah que je me suis servi
de cette voiture les gendarmes se sont
acharnés sur moi fabry tu trompes comme
étant une femme fait 100 m
comme premier gendarme me siffler parce
que je roulais paraît-il au lieu de la
route au lieu à as tu veux dire au mit
l'usure et de la route
ah oui oui somme de dix minutes après je
vais tourner
je peux prendre à court et à la cour
oui à la cour quoi bein un raccourci
voie à la basse et au coup de sifflet
deuxième genre d'homme qui suivait je ne
l'avais pas vu car je ne possède pas de
deux proviseurs moi tu n'as pas de trop
bizarre mais non je n'ai pas de
provisions alors tu aurais peut-être
intérêt à mettre un pied devant troussel
absolument et tu si je n'ai pas de
clignotant tikouti les cas c'est donc
une ans plus tard troisième coup de
sifflet j'ai encore ma moto qui me
demandent pourquoi je n'avais pas mes
rallumer territoire allumés a entendu
dire la faute aux jo m ces phares
allumés salah si je m'arrête au bord de
la route
un quatrième gendarmes qui me dresse
contravention tout sous prétexte que
j'étais mal gars tp mazembe maltais
thème halte était mal garé et valhalla
bon alors je lui dis coûté s'il en est
un on blesse si j'en ai un c'est si j'ai
mon permis de conduire tu sais ce qu'il
m'a répondu qu'il n'accepte écoute
j'aurais jamais dû lui demander cette
rencontre est une autre ce qu'enfin quoi
pour tous bossu très bientôt
j'aimerais conseil moi ah bah oui mais
qu'est ce que tu veux je te dis tout ça
n'est pas ce music mais c'est pas grave
des choses musicale simple et moi mais
je ne sais quel temps qu'on chante ça te
ferait plaisir
elle va aller on change de lire tous en
coeur ça va s'arranger en se pendant
les cats a dit desjardins pas parmi les
quatre plats lit ou l'iran qui ferait
que la vie majeur s'est désisté shops et
des chances mais comme je ne nie pas de
mine war negro a fait attention les gars
ça oui par tradition rudy mainiacs a mis
ce retard izem amis
oui
alors
j'habite pas jouer entre lui et a dit
vouloir devenir amis
[Musique]
il officie lamah le tallec